so you recently got hands-on with dr
clubs that right damn right what do you
think so it's funny because it's one of
these very socially driven racing games
that we're seeing a lot of at the moment
you know yeah but what I rising two
you've got the crew are but the approach
that they're taking is a little bit
different they're focusing a lot on
making the social stuff asynchronous
which basically means you don't need to
be online with your friends at the same
time I find that really cool because I
don't want to have to schedule a game
session around what the other people in
my drug club is doing I want to actually
sort of just jump in whenever I have the
chance and try and tackle one of their
challenges or one of their lap times or
one of their best decisions whatever
it's going to be we've spoken in the
past about our challenge system which
feels like it's going to be the main way
that people are going to play the game
certainly internally like that's the
thing that's getting everybody excited
that's the thing we keep coming back to
and this is a way to play asynchronously
with your friends online it doesn't mean
you have to be there at the same time as
them it's less intimidating than perhaps
doing a head-to-head race but crucially
you're still competing and you're still
collaborating but there are multiple
ways to take part in that so for example
you could you can be the person that
sets the fastest lap times and you can
be all about you know straight racing
getting your you're driving line
absolutely perfectly that's how you're
going to earn your your points your fame
you could be the drift guideline you
could be the person that just likes
drifting well you're going to earn your
fame that way you may be somebody that
just likes to play a particular brand of
Carla you may be a fan of mercedes-benz
for example well you can own fame just
by taking part in events using
mercedes-benz cars all of you will will
you know collaborate and help increase
the fame of the club in the same way but
you're all doing different things it
seems like they've also got like a group
functionality going as well right
similar to that of the crew but they're
not called Cruz obviously yeah yeah well
they were talking about how the drive
club itself is the main focus they
originally started out a bit more like
clams or builds like they were much
bigger 30 40 50 people um but it wasn't
given as the right feel for the game and
we we brought it down to 12 towards the
beginning of the year
and then brought it down even further to
six and that's what we fixed on and we
found with six players like these are
your closest friends right these are
either you know them in real life or you
play regularly with them online but
these are your closest friends that
means that everybody has a specific role
nobody can really hide you know
everybody's got something to do they
feel part of something bigger they don't
feel just like a cog in the machine you
join a drive club and you stay in that
club you don't sort of pop between them
and you're sort of earning points to go
towards a pool for your entire club
since we like the kind of going for a
more social aspect in the game as well
like and I can imagine like you know the
crew being a similar game and also also
focusing on the social aspects I'm
wondering where driveclub is going to
take like their social interactions and
abilities to let players connect with
the Marvel yeah well when I was speaking
to the developer he was saying their
idea of socialism isn't just pushing
content out of facebook and twitter
social is you know being able to share
experiences and share moments with your
friends with the people that you care
about and with the wider community with
you know getting in contact with
strangers in it in a seamless way that's
what connected is that's what socialism
and you know I think I feel like
PlayStation 4 is absolutely at the
forefront of that and it's kind of
pushing a different approach to gaming
perhaps then maybe we were used to in
the past it all stems from starting with
the core driving experience that you
have to make that good before you build
anything else and and at its core if you
strip away all the layers of meta game
all the different reward structures all
the social elements at its core
driveclub is a game you know made by car
enthusiasts for car enthusiasts you know
we did start with trying to recreate
that emotional thrill of driving these
vehicles if we hadn't have got that
right it doesn't matter what else is on
there you know it doesn't doesn't matter
how many rewards streams we have our
anything else because the base mechanics
just simply wouldn't have been there so
everything we've added everything we've
we've put on top of that was done I
guess safe in the knowledge that we got
the basics right first